revient sur cette attaque avec vous
dominique trinquent ancien chef de
mission militaire française auprès des
nations unies bonjour à vous merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation sur
france 24
on l'a vu donc en crimée des explosions
sont survenues dans ce dépôt de
munitions russe la version la plus
probable est celle d'une première
attaque effectuée avec succès par
l'armée ukrainienne peut-être donc grâce
à des missiles de longue portée livré
par un allié occidental cela
signifierait le franchissement d'une
ligne rouge pour vladimir poutine
bonjour et merci d'autres invitations
alors écoutez ce dont on peut être
quasiment sûr même si les ukrainiens ne
revendique pas cette attaque c'est que
c'est bien sûr l'objet d'une attaque
ukrainienne en revanche les moyens
utilisés restent
sujets à caution on parle de missiles de
longue portée mais il faut rappeler que
les américains avaient dit qu'il ne
livrerait pas de missile à longue portée
et lors d'un commentaire hein un
officiel ukrainien a parlé de l'aide
fournie par la résistance
donc on peut retenir deux possibilités
soit la résistance par sabotage ou par
utilisation de drôles locale a frappé
très précisément des dépôts de munitions
qu'elle connaissait et a provoqué
l'incident dont on parle soit
effectivement des missiles à longue
portée avec des coordonnées
qui auraient été fournies ou un guidage
finale par la résistance ont permis
cette attaque en tout état de cause ceci
rentre dans la stratégie ukrainienne qui
est de frapper les dépouilles la
logistique et tous ceux qui concourent à
la résistance russe dans la région de
kherson à l'est à l'ouest pardon du
nieppe qui est semble-t-il le prochain
objectif des armées ukrainiennes
par ailleurs j'en parlais dans les
titres le conseil de sécurité de l'onu
ah tiens donc aujourd'hui une réunion
d'urgence avec au coeur des
préoccupations cette centrale nucléaire
ukrainienne de sapori jack qui avaient
moscou s'accusent mutuellement d'avoir
bombardé cette centrale c'est désormais
un terrain de guerre il faut le dire
elle est aux mains des russes depuis le
mois de mars pourquoi est-elle si
stratégique pour la russie d'un point de
vue militaire
alors elle est stratégique par la russie
vous l'avez signalé elle a été saisie
dès le début mars et elle est
stratégique
en fait pour la reconstitution de des
territoires conquis par la russie en
ukraine et leur alimentation par
l'électricité donc c'est extrêmement
important sur le plan de l'avenir de
cette région
sur le plan militaire en revanche
aujourd'hui les russes l'utilisent pour
cacher ou pour abriter si vous voulez
ils sont pas tellement cacher mais pour
abriter des lance-roquettes qui leur
permettre de tirer sur la rive ouest du
nieppe ces actions sont naturellement
formellement interdites par les
conventions de genève mais les russes
n'ont pas signer ces conventions de
genève en tout état de cause cette
centrale est essentiel pour la russie
six réacteurs la plus grosse centrale
probablement d'europe qui lorsqu ils
fonctionneront pas ce qu'il faut
rappeler que aujourd'hui ses réacteurs
sont arrêtés permettront d'alimenter
toute la zone sud qui est actuellement
sous contrôle russe donc il ya peu de
chances que soient les russes qui se
tirent dessus en revanche il ya toute
légitimité à ce que les ukrainiens
essaye de ressaisir cette centrale avec
les problèmes caution requise parce
qu'il ne s'agit pas bien sûr de cibler
directement les réacteurs nucléaires
mais justement elle fait aussi office de
boucliers militaire cette centrale ce
qui est très inquiétant
oui c'est ce que je disais les russes
qui met à l'intérieur des lance
roquettes multiples ce qui est tout à
fait contraire aux conventions de genève
et c'est donc inquiétant dans la mesure
ceci met en danger la centrale elle-même
mais encore une fois faut bien voir que
cette centrale n'a rien à voir avec des
centrales de modèles anciens qu'elle est
assez les réacteurs sont très bien
protégées et qu'une nouvelle fois je le
répète ils sont arrêtés aujourd'hui donc
les risques d'incidents nucléaires sont
réduits mais il existe et donc il faut
en tenir compte alors on l'a appris ce
matin là la grande bretagne fournira
crenn encore plus de système de
lance-roquettes qui peuvent frapper des
cibles jusqu'à 80 kilomètres les états
unis on l'a vu on te livrer des
roquettes en juin dans quelle mesure ces
armes peuvent-elles modifier le rapport
de force sur le champ de bataille
alors les armes à longue portée
contribuer à l'application de la
stratégie craignait qui est de taper mes
centres logistiques de taper dans la
profondeur de façon à empêcher les
russes de renforcer leur dispositif est
tout simplement d'amener des munitions
en première ligne dans le cas
particulier de la zone de carson c'est
particulièrement important parce que là
l'offensive que les ukrainiens annonce
dans ce crayon la vise à couper les
forces russes qui sont à l'ouest du
nieppe de façon à empêcher la russie de
disposer d'une tête de pont à l'ouest du
nieppe et de se cantonner à lestre à
l'est d'une y être qui est très large à
cet endroit est peut-être s'ils le
refont s'il réussit même d'en fermer une
partie des forces russes qui se
trouverait ainsi est prisonnière skis
sur le plan psychologique ce très très
dommageable pour le foncier russe actuel
de quel type d'artillerie justement a
besoin l'ukraine en ce moment pour se
défendre alors les lance-roquettes
multiples bien sûr mais vous avez cité
le renforcement moi je citerai surtout
le renforcement américain qui annonce
des missiles anti radar ça veut dire
qu'il s'est d'abord de la très haute
technologie ce que ne faisait pas tout à
fait etats unis aujourd'hui et des
missiles anti-radar ça permet d'une part
de réduire la capacité aérienne de la
russie sur la zone mais aussi de tirer
sur les radars de trajectographie dont
disposent les russes et de mettre ainsi
les missiles anti enfin les les les
missiles longue portée
l'ukrainien hors de portée des russes
donc c'est un une escalade dans le
domaine de la technologie et qui vise à
taper dans la profondeur les russes ce
qui est très utile pour l'enfance et
l'ukrainienne est justement pour
poursuit vivre cette offensive
ukrainienne de à quel point les forces
armées on craignait non besoins sont
tels dépendantes plutôt de l'armement
occidentale
va dans le domaine de la longue portée
elles en sont totalement dépendants ce
sont les lance-roquettes multiples et
rocket donc les missiles dans vienne
parler qui sont dépendants toutefois il
faut reconnaître que l'ukraine qui
disposait d'une capacité
de construction de fabrication
d'armement est très capable de fournir
elle-même un certain nombre et de
modifier un certain nombre d'armement
c'est pour ça que sur l' attaque en
crimée on se pose un peu des questions
sur l'armement qui a été utilisé il faut
se rappeler qu'ils ont utilisé des
drones qui ont été modifiées qui ont pu
taper à très longue portée et en
particulier la la destruction du du
navire moskva russe a probablement été
fait par des missiles qui avait été
modifiée par l'ukraine dont ils ont
besoin de l'armement occidentale
complètement mais ils sont très capables
de modifier ces éléments dominique
trinquant ancien chef de mission
militaire française auprès des nations
unies merci beaucoup à vous pour votre
décryptage sur notre antenne
le ray